[Music]
okay everyone so this
is my spoiler free review of brand new
cherry flavor
this stars rosa salazar who you
recognize from a bunch of animated work
and this is really her time to shine in
a real life role which is exciting she's
a great lead
you got katherine keener and she is also
great in this and of course you got
eric lang who plays lou burke he's great
as well so you have three strong leads
in the show
and it's a show that i had low
expectations for but the trailer
intrigued me but what's great about this
show
is that it's really weird it's weirder
than the trailer show you it's
craziness it's body horror galore it's
disturbing
but it is not weird to just be weird
everything serves a purpose at that
you'll see stuff in the shoe like what
am i watching but it
makes sense for what the character needs
to do and it serves the story says
the best thing to say about the show
besides obviously the acting here which
was
great and really solid writing um
there's two episodes for the ends i
didn't think were great but the rest of
it's
really good it has a nice bow on it this
series
and it has a really strong finale which
is always good but
i really think it is a great beginning
like the first four episodes are great
and i think you'll really enjoy this i
will say though that's with a warning as
in
it's very niche like this has to be your
cup of tea to really like this because i
think it's going to be polarizing
because
you're going to meet people like all
that i didn't like that show and that
just might be biased because they're not
into it like you got to be down with
this type of
really weird out there stuff but i'm
telling you it's not that type that
feels like a cheat and just trying to be
like that it's not a poser like it is
that and it does it well
uh so it's for you know the david lynch
type
fans but it has a hint of breaking bad
in here
and it has a hint of john wick and
it at the end of the day though you can
make all these comparisons but it's a
good story
and it has again a really good main
character plot
so it's gonna not be for everybody but
if you're again
into this crowd of just as weird as you
can get and you like the body [ __ ]
and you can like you can handle a lot of
disturbing stuff uh
you're gonna like it and so for me i'm
into that stuff so i'm gonna give it
you know definitely as someone not
biased that that i just
looked at as a show 8.5 for sure i think
it's a b
it's really solid again i was just a
little disappointed there's two episodes
for the end here
that not really like it gets a little
too much of the conveniences and silly
but other than that really solid i
definitely suggest watching this it's
coming out friday the 13th on netflix so
it's if you get in the spooky mood in
the summer
do it watch it you're gonna enjoy it i
promise
but again if it's not your cup of tea i
don't promise i think
you might just think it's a little too
much and i get it i get it but it's a
good show if you
appreciate good television this is it so
i definitely suggest uh but
i will have a full breakdown spoiler
review the day it comes out the show so
make sure you check that out
please make sure to subscribe to my
channel i do celebrity interviews as
well
please follow me at steve varley show on
twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time